these two producers walk up behind me
and i don't see them and they're
watching me work right yeah they're
sizing me up like maybe i can direct
this low-budget horror film right i go
okay roll camera all right and action
all these worms come to life start
wiggling around i say okay cut the guy
behind the set unplugs the thing the
worm stop moving i look up and there's
these two guys looking at each other
with amazement and they're like hey you
want to go to lunch kid
you didn't even want to direct a guy you
know i carry on about the godfather said
that a moment ago about how he didn't
want to direct the god no you didn't you
didn't want a director you thought the
book was kind of crappy and that it
would be impossible you remember the
book
big part of it i love the book yeah but
half the book is about this lady who has
this gynecological
problem and the guy was going to operate
on her and then he made love with her i
thought it was sort of sleazy yeah and i
in those days when i was young i wanted
to be like you know
fellini or you write beautiful godard
and and be an artist you know so when
when we had this little company to do
personal films with these younger guys
who all became very famous they would
say hey francis we got to make some
money we're broke they're going to chain
up the sheriff is going to chain the
door do this book you know this gangster
book just do what they want don't argue
with them unless we approach you to do
that paramount pictures why do you think
they chose you well you know i oddly uh
when they first got the story there had
been two or three movies about like
gangster mafia there was one with kirk
douglas called the brotherhood and they
were all flops so all the big directors
turned them down
and they decided to make the godfather
very low budget right and a young guy
who and i had been known as a
screenwriter so they figured they'd get
a free rewrite uh and uh and then also i
was italian-american so they figured if
it caught a lot of guff they would say
well he made it you know
it was
very unlikely that i would get that job
but looking at you it's true if you had
won the academy award ready for writing
patton right you would won that already
and so you think if you're a movie
studio you say hey listen maybe we can
get this guy to direct it and he'll
write it that's right we don't have to
worry about it they didn't have a good
script i remember the script it was very
hokey
you read the script you said this is
awful i can fix this i'm going to sit
and do it and you were doing it strictly
for money well i didn't want to do it
because i wanted to make the
conversation i had written the script of
the conversation i was trying to get
money for that and did you say to them
if i'll direct this uh mafia movie for
you if you give me the financing for a
conversation well i wasn't even in
a position to say that i mean i mean
they they finally really just needed
them it was george lucas who said to me
francis we got to get some money in here
you're the only one who can make it so
they hire you to make this film and
you're like oh this book i mean you had
to sit there and read the book and
figure out what the hell can i pull out
i found then i came to admire greatly
mario puzo and when i met him he was
just the most
one neatest man you know and is so
just
simple and and wise you know so i really
i really really came to like him and
admire him a lot what amazing thing
about that cast how do you put it
together i was just gonna make a point
about that what amazes me about you as a
director is that you
stick to your guns number one you know
most guys want a big name in their lead
roles you already had in mind who you
wanted the studio was trying to get you
to get big names
and you stuck to your guns which is not
easy to do when you're a guy who doesn't
have much money and you're down on your
luck you need the money i was very much
the rumor was i was getting fired every
week they didn't like my casting because
you know i had a lot of new actors no
one had heard of al pacino we didn't
have the money for star so we had to
find a new kid when it comes to casting
they wanted the ryan o'neill for michael
for michael yeah ryan or redford even
wow and when i said gee they don't seem
they don't look like
it how could you have that he
know evans correctly said but the
sicilians can be blonde and blue-eyed
which is true but people don't think of
that but my i said but he's gonna have
like since he's a kid who doesn't want
to go and be a gangster he's got to have
it like in his face that he's sicilian
imagine if you didn't stick to your guns
how different that movie would be maybe
not even the success and the script was
said in in modern then the 70s it wasn't
in the 40s right it's cheaper to make a
movie when it's not period right so i
came on this young guy who had no clout
at all said i want to make it period in
new york they wanted to make it 70s in
like st louis or somewhere cheaper
as big as you were on all in the family
i feel like when you decided to really
put your foot down and become a director
and and the first movie of course being
uh spinal tap right
that i feel like you had to prove
yourself all over again like it's so in
a way oh that's meathead yeah you know
[ __ ] him i'm not giving money directly
what does he know and you know it's
exactly the truth in those days
now you see crossover between movies and
television all the time right in those
days tv people were second-class
citizens the movie people were royalty
they looked down on tv you couldn't make
that transition spinal tap was a
mockumentary they call it but nobody had
done that kind of thing it didn't make a
ton of money but then it became a cult
classic yeah yeah and it was so
brilliant it was a goof on the whole
rock and roll industry and people didn't
get it right away i mean when we first
it was hysterical we we previewed it
down in dallas right and people would
come and they watched it that they
didn't know what the hell it was people
come and they said
why would you make a movie about a band
that nobody ever heard of
and one that's so bad
why didn't you make a movie about the
beatles
something like that i said well it's
satire and the guy who shot it this guy
peter smokeler i hired him because he
had shot all these rock and roll
documentaries
and i you know that's why i thought he
was that actually at altamont you know
where the where the stone the stones and
the
hell's angel thing and he he kept saying
the whole time we're shooting he said
what's funny about this right this isn't
funny when people
is real when people don't get it and
people are coming up to you and here you
are first time director do you have just
despair because you're saying to
yourself how the [ __ ] am i going to get
my directing career going people don't
even understand they don't understand
what we're doing albert brooks he did
something that taught me a big lesson he
does a a routine where he plays a mime
and he's basically he's in white face
with the leotard right he walks out on
stage and just never stops talking right
the whole time he says look i'm pulling
the rope there is no rope here he's
doing all this and no laughs nobody
laughed because you know
that's the problem with albert brooks a
lot of people don't get them right all
right so so then two weeks later right
my dad my dad was hosting the first one
now carson's hosting i said albert i was
living i had a house with him
i said albert they called him back and
they said you're going to do carson
again he says well albert what are you
going to do
he says i'm going to do the mind piece i
said what are you crazy i didn't get any
less right he said but it's funny right
i know it's funny but nobody laughed and
shouldn't laughter be part of the
equation hearing this he says it's funny
i'm doing it now he goes back and does
the exact same routine on carson on
carson starts up again nobody laughing
but then carson had never seen it yeah
starts to laugh right and it's gone i
mean he just goes and destroys it i was
there and he felt literally fell off his
chair wow which told the audience oh i
get it he's making fun of mimes he's not
a bad mind he's making fun and then the
audience went and that taught me a
lesson that you just have to stick with
what you feel is so as a performer or
whatever you're doing you gotta you
gotta do whatever you love you gotta
stick with it yeah but it is that is
incredibly ballsy yeah yeah after the
the bit yeah
yeah
when you wrote rocky yeah and and then
finally i mean you were broke and you
write rocky and the studios like it you
finally get accepted and they say okay
look we don't want you say i want to be
the star of this movie and they go look
man
you're nobody that's true
you turned down how much money for them
to just buy the just buy the film and
put i don't know who they want to put in
there they want to put ryan on the old
jimmy khan
they wanted to put nick nolte did people
say to you listen sylvester you'll get
your chance to act sell the movie make
some money including my agents they said
are you crazy this is ridiculous money
360 000 by standards back then no i said
look guys i i really mastered the method
of living on nothing of eating basically
cobwebs and it's okay i'm not i i know
in my mind if i sell it now and it
becomes good don't kill yourself i will
kill myself how long how long did you
have to hold down in other words they
said to you here's 360 000 for wright
and rocky go away and leave us alone
about about three months but to the
here's what's different in hollywood the
producers there
went against the system and had to
mortgage their own houses
mortgage their houses to get the money
up and get the studio behind in the bond
to guarantee try that today yeah good
luck who did you pressure like who was
what studio and who was the united
artist united artist and they sat down
you said we love your script but you
cannot do this and you said i'm walking
away from 360 000. so when did you get
the call that finally okay we'll we'll
let you start it did you have to go
audition for them well no what it is
they finally broke it and said we can do
this film if you're going to be in it we
have a 14 that was a 14 day thing where
we can fire you any time if you do
anything wrong and and more importantly
we can reduce it down to
900 grand all in and if you can do this
thing in under 30 days okay if not it's
it's over so you shoot the whole thing
in 28 days 28 days the whole first
rocket
unbelievable i know it is it's like why
can't i do that every time what happened
because it becomes too important right
it becomes too important if you would
just knock out movies like that without
all that is the truth
no but you're afraid of failure in a
sense i know it's like what happened
it's great when you're working out there
you're changing the back of a a pickup
truck at all there's a certain kind of
energy about it and you don't become so
caught up in my right angle my makeup
this and that and things happen that are
so visceral but you're right as we
become more pampered more spoiled more
reserved we take a little longer into
the settings like that and you know what
you lose your edge you lose your eyes
there's no doubt about it everyone's
best work when you were starving five
years you wrote how long did it take you
to write rocky i mean literally sit down
and start writing it well it took about
this will sound pretentious but it took
three days of which 90 was terrible but
the german the idea was there right that
was it so and then after that it took
maybe 25 rewrites you have to keep going
like one day you'll say can we make the
black guy jamaican can we make this guy
so you have to be okay man you have to
change all the dialogues
was there a period of time where even
you thought you were a fluke like wait a
second okay yeah uh you know i wrote a
good movie here and i did you think it
was all gonna like go away and then did
there come a time where all of a sudden
you went holy [ __ ] i'm really pulling
this off i can do it the first thing
that actually got produced was a film
that i directed reservoir dogs right so
i wasn't like oh wow here's this writer
and now he's trying to be a director i
was bam i was seen as a writer director
from the very beginning so then true
romance comes out right and they already
know who i am and they recognize the
dialogue they recognize the
fairness of the whole thing yeah and
same thing with natural-born killers so
by the time pulp fiction comes out i'm
actually a no at least among the critics
i'm a known entity right and when pulp
fiction came out dude that puts you on
the map it did you would know that
that's my point natural born killers
because they basically came out at the
same time
fiction and natural born killers
but that's my point like you know
seriously then all of a sudden you
that's where you get your confidence
right after paul the reaction of pulp
fiction and then you go like hey wait a
second man i'm really on a roll here and
then every movie after that ends up
doing really well
well
there's an expectation after that yeah
you had jackie brown yeah right by the
way jackie brown came in at the same
year as my movie came out probably
before yeah and um jackie brown did not
win the academy award private parts
wasn't even [ __ ] nominated he was
ineligible like reservoir
well you know one of the things about
jackie brown
behind that was the fact that i like
dealing in genres and insider genres
subgenres right and one of the subgenres
that i think jackie brown deals with is
the hangout movie right and that's a
movie where you get to know the
characters and then you are like dazing
confused is a hangout movie right you
know aren't those movies scary to
produce because sometimes they get too
talky right you can [ __ ] well that
can definitely be an accusation you can
make towards me with complete impunity
why is that because you can fall in love
with your own dialogue no no i don't
think it's uh i don't think it's a bad
thing but i mean my characters like to
talk they sure do yeah yeah right and
unfortunately though playwrights never
get accused of being talky yeah right
that's kind of what they do well yeah
because there's more exposition yeah you
know but movies is tricky movies can
start to feel slow right you've got to
play it just right well yeah hopefully
the idea is at least in my case
is your case
you're creating a rhythm yeah and you're
sailing on that rhythm and you're going
with that rhythm and you can break up
the rhythms and everything but that's
what's stopping it from just being a
talky drag
and so now you got to go write this
thing yeah do you get charged up you're
like [ __ ] i got to get this out of my
head this is going to be oh this is
going to take months does it take months
uh yeah it takes months months do you
get excited about it or are you just
like oh [ __ ] well usually the idea kind
of is okay i'm thinking about this and
if it actually gets me to
start writing actually start writing um
is it torture no no no not at all not at
all because i'm not sure 100 if it's
going to work out or not you don't write
it in order do you you just yeah
oh you do yeah i have to write it like
you go scene one well i don't want to
know i really don't know i don't want to
know what's going to happen in the
second half right i want to i i know how
i wear how i want to start it off and i
started off and hopefully because i have
no idea of an ending yeah well i mean
look i'm dealing with genre story so i
have an idea where it's going okay at
the end of kill bill i was pretty sure
she was going to kill bill but how she
was going to kill bill and wasn't i
wasn't when you write like inglourious
bastards right like do you know
i knew it i didn't i didn't know i was
gonna kill hitler i did not know that
until the day i did it good for you all
right yeah uh was that fun no it was a
blast yeah but you know but i
i figured it would end with a big
mission did they have to stick to the
script or did some of these guys try to
add limb no no no they no they're i'm
paying them to say my dialogue make no
mistake does anyone ever get on the go
quentin i think we have to change these
lines it's not quite what my character
would say and you're like get the [ __ ]
out of here well no no i mean something
i mean that could be a legitimate thing
that an actor says and if they're right
then i'll listen to them but if they're
but if they're wrong or if they're just
too lazy to learn the dialogue and so
they're going to paraphrase it no no
that [ __ ] can't be that is not gonna fly
yeah you were gonna do superman which i
was excited about with nicholas cage's
superman i said this is gonna be great
yeah i was excited about it too yeah and
what went wrong well you know
these studios become like these big
corporations and you just having to like
design characters for happy meals before
you design it for the film you know but
you have such credibility yeah but
they're always you know they they know
that the good batman was the first
batman were you no they didn't they
don't know that nobody's still the
second one they thought was like
i upset mcdonald's because they thought
it was too dark
that's why it was good they thought that
the black stuff coming out of the
penguin's mouth was too close to the
ingredients of their food or something
it was too vile yeah what i heard was
superman they tried to get a whole bunch
of people to do it or whatever what
wasn't working out and and like kevin
smith was just here and written a script
yeah yeah exactly and and then they got
you yeah
and now i said once they got you that's
an automatic green light then we heard
nicholas cage which was very exciting
right he i thought like for the first
time you could like with nick you could
say like
guy who um is clark kent and you could
see the change you could see like
becoming something else right you had a
real good actor in there you also have
some depth to your absolute superman
character that was the one character
that was never really portrayed with any
depth yeah right like and why does
superman have to be the perfect looking
guy anyway he was from another it was a
dude from another planet i know i know
you know it's like when we first were
looking at batman's they were trying to
like
unload like guys that looked like arnold
schwarzenegger you're like you're like
these like strong guys with pointy ears
right right right well i thought it was
amazing when you cast michael king
because i was like michael well nobody
thought that would work right because
but it totally worked and he looks crazy
you know he looks like he looks like he
went he's mentioned all the time right
right he looked demented exactly and you
know and nicholas cage looks like he's
from another planet if you ask me
so i thought he was perfect exactly
exactly so you had him lined up he was
committed oh yeah yeah absolutely and
and uh and you had a script or no well
you know at those at studios you don't
have scripts unfortunately
that's how it works
yeah i mean unfortunately you don't even
need a script yeah i i never i have
trouble do you have don't you have
trouble reading i hate reading those
scripts i have trouble even reading my
own script
so you mean to tell me you would have
made superman without a script uh well
that's what we were doing really yeah
they were making it no kidding no we
were like we were doing tests we were
doing all this stuff but you know it
just was crazy i mean the producers they
didn't i had one meeting where we were
looking at the suit and and the studio
and the producers were going you know we
don't want the like the suit you know
we're afraid of the red under they
wanted to have them on like michael
jordan shorts right like oh no
they they said too like and this
the costume desire tonight we were
looking at each other like we almost
died
um we see him wearing corduroy as
superman like corduroy i i don't even
understand so those are elements from
another planet they don't have quarter
iron
then they said maybe give them boots but
you know like uh on the side of a van
like like with flames on it right right
right yeah make him into fire imagine
right that was more closer to the super
yes it was absolutely
first of all when did they ask you to
present at the uh
not long before someone must have
dropped out are you excited by that to
present at the oscars or do you not care
about that yeah no i think it's an honor
it's kind of fun i had a documentary
that was nominated so i was really
excited to be there is that the one you
shot on your iphone no that was a music
video yeah well how do you shoot who did
you shoot that for uh a band called
edward sharp and the magnetic zeros all
right they're a band i don't know that
band they they approach you because they
hear you're a good director yeah they
knew me and they knew i knew their music
and and i had said a couple years ago i
want to shoot a music video and i said
we could even shoot it on an iphone and
then the iphone got like really great
it's pretty good the quality yeah now
you can shoot on 4k it looks great and
so we went for it it turned out well
when you say we so this band approaches
you they obviously don't have a lot of
money right so you have to figure out a
way to shoot this thing rather than get
involved with it how expensive is it to
shoot an iphone video it's got to be
very cheap it's very cheap you know what
we did though is we put a lot of lenses
on it you know you take still camera
lenses i had an amazing dp a woman named
reed morano who's like the coolest chick
in the world who pays for this the
record company well you know we once we
were shooting it on the iphone then
apple kind of stepped in to help us
make the production work because then
you know because they don't want to look
like jerks they're like please don't
make it look bad right
is it possible to make the video that
you saw in your head on an iphone yeah
absolutely and it looked good it looks
really good and i don't think anyone
believes it was on an iphone i got to
look that up i've seen guys shoot stuff
on gopro and stuff and it looks
unbelievable yeah and that movie
tangerine last year was on an iphone
that was the iphone 5. so it's really
come a long way
do you film the artist singing and can
you sync up everything perfectly
no kidding yeah it's there's there's
challenges but we had an amazing crew
what are the challenges because it's
just the technology the technology is
tricky you know for one thing the phone
is very light so it's hard to to have a
handheld shot that's very that's stable
and the other thing is that you have to
kind of pull focus while you're shooting
at the same time you don't have a focus
puller next to you and the exposure is a
little bit trickier so it is amazing are
you one of these people are you like a
nun nick that runs around with your
iphone all the time are you constantly
taking pictures of yourself and other
people are you are you
are you chained to your iphone oh god i
mean i i think i am in too much i mean
but i'm still the person that refuses to
accept that there's wi-fi on airplanes
right like now that you people can reach
you on an airplane i just pretend i'm
not aware of that
how do you get to be
the director i mean where do you come
from how do you do that where'd you grow
up i went straight from being a truck
driver to being a film director is it
true what happened yeah no kidding
exactly all you got to do is stand there
and say i'm the director
did you go to film school or something
no no nothing no well what i used to do
is i'd uh
i was working as a truck driver on the
weekends i drive down to usc i live in
los angeles right i lived in orange
county at the time a truck driver yeah i
was truck driver i'd drive down to usc
i'd go in and for the cost of the
xeroxing i would xerox all these like
doctoral dissertations on optical
printing and film stock film emulsions
and all that stuff build up these big
binders of like how everything was like
a total gearhead so i gave myself like a
full college education for
about 120 dollars wow so you're saying
your whole
while you were a truck driver yeah you
were just fascinated with sort of uh how
they did special effects and that kind
of stuff but it was a hobby for you yeah
it was a hobby you never dreamt of being
a filmmaker oh no i was starting to get
serious about it i just hadn't busted a
move yet because and how old were you at
this point when you were being tried
24 25 really i was married lived in a
little house
so you're telling me
you're driving a truck
how do you make the transition to be the
director of how do you get on a set and
was your first movie terminator one uh i
got i got hired to do this film called
piranha 2 and they fired me after 10
days and what did you get hired to do
directed directed yeah piranha 2. rana 2
yeah the absolutely the best flying
piranha film ever made was it a jaws
rip-off
yeah absolutely but they hired you based
on what
based on well
you got a second for a story yeah i'm
working for roger corman right right low
budget filmmaker and we're working on
this horror picture called galaxy of
terror right and i had to do this scene
where this guy's gotten his arm chopped
off and there's like
maggots on the arm right but they don't
really use maggots they use meal worms
right so i'm doing this shot and the
mealworms aren't doing anything i was a
second unit director right so it's my
first big shot right you know so and let
me explain the audience second unit
director means the guy he's not the
primary director he's the guy who goes
out and shoots like a lot of different
things the director doesn't want to do
right exactly right so it's the lowest
grade cleanup stuff right so i'm doing
this insert shot of this arm and the
worms aren't doing anything so i i took
a piece of zip code you know electrical
cord and put it underneath the arm and
buried it so you couldn't see it right
there's a guy behind the set when i say
action he plugs in the electrical cord
right all right so now these two
producers walk up behind me and i don't
see them and they're watching me work
right yeah they're sizing me up like
maybe i can direct this low-budget
horror film i go okay roll camera all
right and action all these worms come to
life start wiggling around i said okay
cut the guy behind the set unplugs the
thing the worm stopped moving i look up
and there's these two guys looking at
each other with amazement and they're
like hey you want to go to lunch kid
well yeah that's how that's how i got
any any guy who can make worms move on
command that's pretty good
so so so you start doing some low budget
stuff somebody takes some sort of
interest in you unless you do that right
and you have enough you never even
worked like a movie camera or anything
and someone gave you so i was doing
stuff you know i was great i had the
camera up on my shoulder you already had
gotten rid of the truck and yeah ditched
the truck and ditched the the suburban
lifestyle and was you know where did
these ideas come from i mean where do
you you know this terminator well oh i
thought you were asking me where my
ideas come from please i know i'm
getting a little tired of kissing
james's ass i don't know where your
ideas come from isn't it amazing the
whole process you don't know where your
ideas come from you're not a religious
man are you no you think god put them
there or something they come from dreams
so wherever dreams come from wow